[Music]
not in everyone and thanks for the
organizer for the opportunity to share
what we do at so far with you today so
today I'm going to talk about how we use
machine learning in financial credit
risk assessments my name is Soledad
galleys just to say a few words about me
I have a PhD in molecular biology and
then it is a 8 years of research in
neuroscience in University College
London and I finally joined SOPA as part
of the data science team where I
contribute to the generation of insight
through data analytics and machine
learning so you may wonder who are SOPA
I wonder who so far where before I
joined them sapa is some digital finance
company and basically it was the first
peer-to-peer lending platform in the UK
and it was founded in 2004 I just want
you to get an idea of the scale that
we're working at at SOPA we have lent
money we have million more than 2
billion pounds since foundation and we
have learned money to more than 240,000
people I think it's out some people
choose to actively invest their money
with us so why did I join SOPA so what
attracted me from this company is that
machine domain is at the heart of what
we do and we use state-of-the-art
machine learning to produce or models
basically we can use every single
algorithm that is out there to produce
or to try and build the most accurate
models and we also work in an agile
manner so we work fast and we deploy
fast and we generate our own software
which is good at the time of deployment
because it allows us to produce and
deploy quite quickly another thing that
is very important at least for me is a
very end to end seem interesting inter
team collaboration so the data
scientists are working in close
proximity with the risk analysts that
provide some of the domain knowledge and
we're also it's also working in close
proximity with the developers that are
the ones that are going to take to life
or they're actually our research so in
the philosophy and lending model at SOPA
what we do is we put in contact
investors we want to invest their money
with borrowers that are looking for a
low rate loan so basically when an
investor put the money into so far we
match it to a borrower that is looking
for a lousy loan low rate loans say to
improve the house or to buy a car or
whatever they want and when this more
aware returns they don't need to soap up
with the interest this interest is
passed directly on to the investor so I
allowing this circulation of money and
by managing risk we are allowed to
provide low rates to the borrowers and
higher returns to the investors but in
order for this peer-to-peer lending
model to occur as so far we need to
handle all types of financial associated
risk and this risk includes credit risk
and it also includes fraud prevention
and we use machine domain for that and
we also use machine learning for example
to detect a thermal if the document has
been modified so if someone is trying to
upload a document that is false we use
machine learning for that and we also
use machine learning for example to
determine the success of our marketing
campaigns among other things but today
I'm going to talk about the experience
the journey that we had at Soper to
build our credit assessment model from
beginning to an end so what is credit
risk credit risk is the risk of default
or any acquire that by a person and put
in lay terms credit risk is the risk
that a person to whom we have borrowed
money will not be able to pay it back
and we want to assess and mitigate risk
for three main reasons the first one is
we want to lend responsibly so we don't
want to lend money to a person if that
is going to hurt their financial
situation because they cannot pay it
back and we also owe to our investors so
we don't want them to lose their money
and finally we want to keep our
reputation as a responsible and prudent
gender so that's why we need to manage
credit risk so hopefully today in this
talk I'm going to take you through the
process of creating a machine learning
algorithm to chartered credit risk and
this involves the very first steps which
is data gathering and also creating the
target definition which is basically
what do we call risk
and after we have the rate of it on the
target we have to clean the data we have
to pre-process the variables in a way
that we can feed them into machine
learning algorithms and when we have
done that we want to select the
variables that are more predictive and
once we've done that we'll build the
machine learning models typically and
then we can add a negative complexity
through model stacking I'm going to talk
to say a few words about that and then
once we've done all this process how do
we actually take it to life so the first
thing you need to build a machine
learning model is data so how do we get
the data Sapa gets data from credit
agencies various agencies and
institutions that gather and store data
about financial information of people in
general and the information that they
provided information on mortgages credit
cards correct accounts and we can get
information about how much money people
have in those accounts how many accounts
they have for how long have they helped
them have they paid have they notes for
all this information we get from credit
agencies and we also use information
that the applicants provides to Sapa at
the time of application for example what
do they want the loan for do they have a
job how a what kind of job they have
what is the salary etcetera so bettering
these two data sets together for you to
have an idea we end up with around 3,000
characteristics per person and we got
the data for a few several hundred
thousand borrowers so once we have the
data set then we need to define the
target the target is what we want our
machine learning models to predict so we
want to predict risk so how how do we
determine target the predicts risk
basically we want a vector a target that
will say that will categorize people as
whether this person is at the financial
difficulty or not and the way we do that
or in order to do that what we do is we
monitor the financial accounts of
customers for several months and we look
for signs of financial difficulty
financial difficulty may involve default
for example they just couldn't pay the
debt back I can also look for signs of
missed payments in any one month so if
we see any signs of financial difficulty
in mathematic
terms we did that word where a zero and
if we don't see any sign of financial
difficulty
very mathematical things with a sign a
board over a one so what we end up at
the a at the end of this exercise is
with a data set that will have hundreds
thousands of a several hundred thousands
of rows which are alvaro with three
thousand characteristics which are the
columns and a single sign the vector
with one of zeros determine whether the
customer is at the financial risk
financial difficulties or not the next
step now that we have our data set is to
pre-process variables right so variables
usually don't come in a way that you can
use them straight away so we have to do
something about that so what can we do
while we pre process differently
categorical variables and numerical
variables categorical variables are
variables I have labels instead of
numbers for example gender instead of
number you would have female or male so
what can we do with that the categorical
variables they have a lot of null values
null values is when we actually don't
have a value for a customer for that
variable and there are a few options you
can choose to throw the data away but
then you would be throwing away a lot of
data so you don't really want to do that
what we want to do is to replace those
null values for something else
and how can we do that in the
traditional way you can choose to
replace those values by a random sample
of the data so you choose your variable
whenever you have a variable you select
a random sample and you fill the gaps
that would be one way the other way is
to replace the variable by the most
frequent category if you have a category
that appears a lot then you choose to
fill all the gaps with that category we
don't like to do that at supper because
we think that if the value is missing it
is for a reason if we don't have
financial information for that person
there has to be a reason so then we
choose to feel or what I got differently
and we create an additional category
that we call missing so whatever there
was a null value now there is a missing
label so then there are also rare values
that you can touch that you can have in
your categories for example if your
category if your variable sorry is City
you can imagine that cities like London
will have a lot of representation in the
variable because the population is huge
but smaller cities or small towns we
have lower representations say like
broken house so then when you have rare
categories what happens is that the
mullah tends to overfeed because they
will think that everybody were coming
from that city behaves like the only one
border was that it's all so we don't
want that to happen so then we want to
remove the rare values and how can we do
that again so you can take a random
sample of the variable and feel they can
feel and replace the very values with
that but you can choose and replacement
by the most frequent category but we
don't think that this is the way to go
so what we do at River is we are
generational category that is called
rare value so now every time in your
category you have city like or Museum
kings or broken earth you will have
activity levels it's called rare value
and once you have your label is replaced
and your variable is full we need to put
that to Louie to transform that into a
number so that we can fit it to a
machine learning model and how can we do
that again there are a variety of
methods you can replace each label by
the frequency it has so like if you have
1,000 customers from London you will
replace London by 1,000 or 1000 divided
is the total number of followers you can
also assign an ordinal values like if
you suspect that your variable is
ordinal Excise days of the week you can
put one in Monday and you can put a 7 in
Sunday you can do one hot encoding I
don't think I have time to describe that
here and what we do at SOPA is we assign
a value before but before we assign an
order to the variable so what we do is
like for each label in the category in
in the variable so we measure the value
of the target then we order decreasingly
depending on the value of the target and
then we put a number so say for example
we take London and I see that the
default right there is 60% so that one
is my highest default right I put in
number one and then I evaluate the next
city the next seat is an exit and then I
say for example broken house just to
give the example my default rate there
is zero so that one is the lowest right
so I assigned according to the fold rate
from the highest to the lowest and then
the highest we will number one the
like on label will be number two so what
until I put the number two the rest so
that basically we are assigning some
order first and then I'm given the
number according to the force due to the
order and that allows me already to
capture some information in the variable
at a time of transformation so then we
have all activities now in the form of
numbers what do I do with the numerical
variables again numerical values can
have null values which is the lack of
information for everyone borrower in
that variable in particular and you can
also have outliers Allah is more or less
the same as a rare value right so it's a
number that is way far in the
distribution of the numbers present in
the body also make all your your
customers look like this and then you
have this one that looks like this so it
tends to make models in particular
linear models overfitting so then you
want to do something with those values
and the way we start to learn our values
and outliers is virtually very similar
see again you can replace them by a
random sample of the variable or you can
replace in this case by the median or
the mean so basically the most frequent
value although we can do what we do at
sofa actually is to replace that number
for a number that is very far in the
distribution but still in the
distribution right so if you imagine the
normal distribution here and our layer
was here we bring it to the end so we
make it within the population but C is
different from the rest of the customers
so this is for you know cleaning data
but now what at the moment of using
these variables in machine learning
models there is still some more
pre-processing that you need to do
depending on the machine learning model
that you want to use so for linear
models like logistic regression and also
naval networks the performance of the
model benefit from normalizing the data
from squeezing the values of each
variable between minus 1 and 1 so this
is what we do we normalize the data and
here specifically normalization is
dividing the variable subtracting the
mean and divided by the variance there
are other ways of normalizing as well as
if you choose and another important
thing is that linear methods like
logistic regression they assume L
relationship between your variable and
the target and that is more often than
not not the case so the variables are
not linearly related with your target so
it is a good idea to try and make a
linear transformation to find the linear
association between your variable and
the target and these confirmations
typically or most famous I'll ability
logarithmic transformation you can also
make square roots or you can basically
use any function that you like that
finds a linear association between the
variable and the target what we do at
SAAP is something that we call driven in
and basically it makes a tree find the
linear cuts in the variable so how does
this work
so for each single variable so I grabbed
one variable let's say salary and I buy
I built their a classification tree a
very shallow one one two splits three at
most so what it does the classification
tree is within that variable it finds
the main cut that will make the best
separation between you know defaulters
and no defaulters or people at risk and
of people are not not at risk so that in
a sense is kind of finding the linear or
associations between the variables are
not so then a I can find three or four
cuts within the variable that kind of
make that variable more linear to the
target than it was before and then after
I've made the trees what we do is that
we replace the value of the variable by
the probability outputted by that single
classification and regression tree if
that makes sense
so after so now we have a dataset that
is ready to be fed into the machine
learning model something very important
particularly when you're working in a
commercial environment is a feature of
variable selection right and here I
specifically say reducing the number of
features from a few thousand to a few
tens and why is this important for a
variety of reasons first it's easier to
implement so when a developer has to
code this is the code to call the
information about the customers is much
faster if they have to call only 50
variables than if they have to call 1000
variable
the second reason is that it's faster so
a model that is trained and predict
using sense of variables is much faster
than one that uses three thousand
variables and we want to produce a
smooth experience for the person that
comes to the platform and finally it's
more reliable so as you can see like we
rely on credit agencies information so
the more variables that we use from them
the more the room that is to bring a
mistake happen right if something
crashes on the accreditations we have it
has lighted info on what we do so
therefore we want to we want to reduce
the feature selection to a few things
and how do we do that and it is a
massive drop from two thousand to a
pretense so we do it in two stages here
on the first stage we build a
classification tree for each variable so
work like that take variable number one
I be like rusev occasion three versus
the target and I look at the accuracy or
the rocker you see a third model if that
variable is predictive I keep it if that
barrier is not predictive at all I just
drop it and at the same time I will a
random forestry using all the 3000
variables random for it is able to
provide information about the importance
of the feature it will run the features
of this one it's the most important so
this one is the least importance and
then I look at the importance that it
gave to the variables and I remove all
the ones that have 0 importance so by
doing these two things I'm able to fast
from 3,000 variables to a couple of
hundred and ones that we have a couple
of hundred I think it's a good idea to
let each machine learning model decide
what is best for them and we do that in
a process that is called recursive
feature elimination so we do recursive
feature elimination for each machine
learning model and how does recursive
feature elimination work so you build
one model say it's random forest again
with an example on your 500 variables
you measure the performance of the model
then you remove one feature you measure
the performance again if the performance
dropped then the feature was important
so you want to put it back if the
performance didn't drop then the feature
was unnecessary so you can discard it
and then you do the same with the next
feature and the next feature and the
next feature until you find the smallest
set of features that have the higher
performance for the
machine learning model in this case
random Horus and we do the same for
logistic regression and we do the same
for HP boost and then it takes the day
society to kind of scan all those models
and find the one the world's the best so
it says the last page is a little bit
artistic if you want so now that we have
the variables pre-process and we
selected the ones that we want to use
the next step is to build the final
machine them in models and to optimize
it so what we do is on the types of
variables that we selected we build a
battery of machine learning models and
just to give you an idea with a linear
models logistic regression and multi
adaptive regressive splines within three
borders including random forests and
gradient boosted trees and we also be
the neural network and we hope that
these models will give a high
probability to customers that can
actually play the roles with ease and we
attribute a low probability to customers
that may encounter some financial
difficulties at the time of paying the
loan so we have now a variety of models
we have like seven models we want to
test the performance we want to know
which one is the best which one are we
going to use so their way of assessing
the performance of the models there are
several ways in fact the one that we use
the tapa is the estimation of the rock
you see the rock a you see tells you for
each probability value how much success
we have and what is your trade-off right
I think let's say I choose a treasure of
0.5 and I'm going to say that if the
probability is higher than 0.5 then I
will determine that this customer is a
healthy customer so the rocker using is
your an indication for that treasure of
how many times how many healthy
customers the model was able to pick and
for that amount of healthy customers how
many false positives it gets like how
many times did it say that this customer
would be able to repay
when you actually couldn't right so it
gives me an indication of the success of
the model and ideally I want the model
that captures the greatest amount of
healthy customers and the lowest amount
of false positives I think the lowest
number of times saying that this
customer could pay when
to the coolant and for those of you
familiar with three models you will know
that themselves there are in symbol
algorithms so what I assemble models so
basically this is a classification and
regression three so in a random forest
or in a gradient boosted please there is
not just one tree to make the prediction
there are several trees to make the
prediction and how are they deal so you
have your data you select the sample of
your data you win the classification
tree you extract another sample of your
data you win the second classification
tree you just like another sample of
your data you will design specification
3 and so on so you haven't moved it to
the specification 3 typically hundred
and each one of them is slightly
different from the other they are not
very similar they are slightly different
and then we ask them kind of to vote so
we measure the average probability of
all of them and this was shown back in
the late 70s that improves the accuracy
of the prediction quite dramatically
right so as an example imagine like if
you want to sell your house would you go
and ask only one state agent or would
you go and ask 10 state agents and then
get the average probability or the
average price so the model here is doing
the same and this is intrinsically the
way random for its work
and gradient boosted trees work as well
but we can actually do the same with
logistic regression in a process that is
called buying of the predictors and this
was also described in the late 70s so by
Univ the practice works very very
similar so we spread one sample of the
data set and within the logistic
regression they will suck another sample
within another model and so on then we
end up with say 100 models slightly
similar but not equal and then we have
them also the probability and then we
get the average probability of those
hundred models to predict the
probability of repayment and we have
observed that for our data that improves
the ROC AUC of the second decimal which
is quite a big improvement so now that
we have these all the models and
hopefully have selected the one that
works the best etapa we have also played
a little bit with model stacking and I
want to tell you later what this is
so Morris packing is a technique that
allows you to build another machine
learning models on top of the individual
machine learning models right so you
have all your machine learning models
that you build in the first stage each
one taking into account the tens of
features and put in an output
probability and then these probabilities
you can fill into a second machine
learning model and you can ask them to
predict the probability of report of
repayment now based on the probabilities
instead of in the create agency's
variables and these typically improve
the performance of your learning
algorithm because it is able to capture
where each one of those models is doing
well and it is able to discredit where
each one of those models is doing bad
so meta modeling can be as simple as
just averaging the probabilities so you
can take an average of all these
probabilities I'm into meta model or you
can take the average of these two or the
three it's up to you and also you can
take you can build another machine that
we model so here you would have a
logistic regression using those
variables or you can have a grabbing
boosted trees using those variables as
input right so it is up to you it's very
creative
it's a lot of room to play so what we
have shown up so far and this is our
experience so when evaluating the
individual models they're unsurprisingly
perhaps we found that gradient boosted
trees and neural networks are the ones
that individually perform the best
so those centers so those are able to
classify the greatest amount of healthy
people without capturing false negatives
and when we actually take the
probability of these two together and we
use it to make the final probability we
find that that increases the performance
even more and we have played with a lot
of probability combinations for us and
we have also been several machine
learning models using that as an inputs
using the probabilities as an input but
what we have observe is that they post
in performance given our models is not
big enough to justify the expense of
resources both computational and human
to implement the
like a machine learning model on top of
that so we decided that we would not go
this way at least not for this exercise
so if you bear with me for the whole
talk I mean what we have what we have at
the end is like a dataset with sense of
variables we also have a target within
several models we selected the two that
work the best and we have average the
probability and the average probability
of the best performing model is the one
that we are actually using to classify
the probability so to classify not to
determine the probability of a person
that comes to a platform of repaying the
loan if we were going to give it to them
so what do we do next
we need to bring this to life right so
we need for each customer that comes to
a platform we need to score them quickly
with this model and how do we do that
well ahsoka we have developed a toolkit
that we very creatively have named
predictor predictor things on top of
Python and it uses numpy and pandas to
pre-process the variables to remove no
valuables to make all the variable
transformation and it also uses
scikit-learn for the traditional machine
learning models and for recursive
feature elimination we use fires to
present to build the multi adaptive
recursive lines we use X abuse for
gradient boosted trees we use scales
from neural networks we use mud from nib
and c1 for data visualization and it
data science with most of our research
using Gupta notebooks that allows for
easy you know visualization of your data
of your genius so we do a research using
predictor which means that we don't have
to write code from scratch every time we
want to pre-process data and build the
machine learning algorithms because all
of that is in the functionality of
predictor itself and we also used to
lichte to deploy so basically when a
customer comes to us what is assessing
that customer is a Python script Python
software predictor so this allows to
decrease the overhead between research
and development because our developers
don't have to write everything from
scratch in any other language right they
just implement all the tools available
in Python for that our predictor is
flexible so which means that we can
improve it every time so for
sample we started with logistic
regression and maths in a second
exercise we added extra boost and now we
have added carers and we have also added
an in-house records the feature
elimination using XG boost basically you
can modulate some complexity of stock on
top of it as you progress in your
research and as I mean it is proprietary
but we are actually thinking of open
sourcing in so I hope I could give you a
flavor of what we do a topper of what it
takes for an end-to-end machine learning
process to be built and I would like to
thank you for your attention then no we
throw an entire book I mean which is not
that which throws entire logos every
time a customer comes here says an
individual is that your question okay
no no it will be just entire book yeah
yes it's it's okay it is a fair question
I think the question today is like we do
univariate feature selection and that's
a risk because a variable may have
interactions with other variables do we
take care of that the answer is yes so
first I will build a tree and we find
the rock a you see for that variable
versus the target if the rocker you see
is around 0.5 which basically means that
is random we remove it and then very
unlikely if you put it back it will be
successful in any case in a stage we go
over all the variables that we remove
one by one in a recursive featured
addition and if I find that it improves
a performance on a certain threshold I
will put the feature back okay yes
exactly this was his process again
produce that two class classifiers like
a guy is gonna pay back instead or it is
actually a probability measure because
it makes not actually the same thing yes
I want to ask this because open banks
have like obligations deviation because
of Ostia to like producer scenario
analysis like very recently like what
what is very square its closing on in
there like 1 percent worse scenarios and
that's what you really need yes okay so
this I think the question is if we are
output in a classifier just you know
lend or not lend or if we're output in a
probability so our models all of them
they output a probability of repayment
and what we do with the probability
later only say so if the customer has a
very high probability of repayment which
means that it's actually very healthy
financially customer so that we put it
in a high market and which our lowest
interest rate and then if there is
someone that we found that is a little
bit more risky we are still happy to
lend if they are going to pay higher
rates right so this is the way we work
with the probability on top of what I
showed that is of course the entire
business metric that you know to satisfy
with compliance regulations and all of
that but I didn't have time to talk up
with of that here we want to save this
business item this is our how important
is it for you to be able to explain why
one customer is more risky than the
other and basically on top of the image
the neuromas
we're kinda working process and usually
the problem might be that they don't
have like exclusive answer wife like one
customer is riskier than the other like
house yes fortunately at SOPA
stakeholders like including the CEO and
the product managers and etc they are
very acquainted with machine learning so
they have an idea of how trees work how
Neverland this was work and they have an
idea that this is kind of black box see
if you want the problem is when we have
to talk with our investors because they
don't necessarily have the idea so we
would have to bring it down to line
terms we will have to show
so basically when we can we try to
explain whether tree does very likely
that's not the case because they may not
understand so we have to show them the
numbers I think how our models are
performing to change while not when it
comes to machine learning algorithms
that I'm aware of
there are legislations about what
variables you can use so we cannot use
gender for example we cannot use age but
yeah
yeah well the first thing is that we
have to comply with the regulation so
variables like age and gender with
cannot use so we don't pass them to the
model this is just illegal so we don't
do that there may be account with some
particularly look for correlations
between H and probability of repayment I
don't particularly find that H is a
great predictor yes anyone we are blind
to race to the game with so I couldn't
tell you if there is any correlation
between race and address because
although we are blind to that
information so information that is
illegal we are blind so I cannot use it
to insert anything to begin with
yes so for this exercise we actually
don't have a balancing problem we can
find that 40 percent of the people we
could define that they have missed
payments or defaulted on any other
account other than loans which is what
we lend but we do have the problem for
flood for example the tiny amount of
flow is very very tiny so what we do in
that case is we rebalance the data set
so basically we multiply we over sample
from the fraud class to over represent
it in the data set and then we adjust
the probability accordingly yes so the
beauty of a model like this is that it
allows you to play so basically it comes
to the business needs and the economical
situation of the moment and you can
decrease or increase the attrition so if
you are in a very stable economic
situation and we have a lot of money
then we can lend a lot so then we will
allow a lot of more positives but if the
situation changes then we are all false
negatives and situation changes
basically we do exactly the opposite so
you can play with that pressure
depending on the situation it's not a
set rule
there could be and it's particularly
important for cases where people is new
to the UK for example then you don't
have financial history because they have
not been trading here we have been
started to do some research but we
haven't gone deeply into that but I mean
there are agencies that gather social
data for example you could work with
that we haven't done that at the moment
also it's quite regulated so it's not
you know very easy to go in there but
anything
the logistic regression that we do
already is quite developed because we do
bargain of logistic regression so I
don't have one I have 100 models and I
already linearized the variables with a
very complex way so my logistic
regression or the logistic regression
with what's up why it's already quite
predictive if I have to give you the
numbers I think ok so from a simple
logistic regression to a balian of the
predictors I would say that there is an
order of the second decimal so it would
go from 0.9 to 0.93 or something like
that and then the gradient boosting and
neural networks or even better and it's
not just because that would be
benchmarking it versus ourselves we also
birch market versus with the predictive
variables that are out there or very
select rate agencies provides predicting
variables and we benchmark it with those
as well
I don't think I'm allowed to share those
numbers unfortunately can you cope with
traumatic life events that change the
nature of somebody's risk that would
let's say for example somebody's to be
married to a spendthrift partner and
they've just completed a divorce so
their credit gets the trash for the past
but might actually month quite
reasonable for the future mm-hmm and yes
and we don't do that from the machine
learning perspective then we have a
dedicated team that is going to tackle
individual situations like this yeah
okay you want
1,200 yes yes and what I don't that
they're not important because I did the
three versus the target and the accuracy
of in the rock agency was 0.5 which is
random and then or the importance by a
random forest was zero so that tells me
some information but then like going
back to the question that the other
person asked me so once we have our
final data set I just want to be
absolutely sure that I didn't miss
anything important so I will put the
feature one by one and if it is
important and I'd missed it originally I
keep it basically
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]